[Music]  you get to meet everybody who's been the  person that you met rich just blew your  mind just completely blew your mind John  Stamos  John Stamos I saw he was at a party and  I turned into those perfect I was a  perverted guy I was like following him  into rooms and like staring at his ass  and just when I met him and I didn't  want to meet him because it's not good  when I meet people who I really idolize  yeah and it's just it's just never good  and so I was avoiding him and my friends  brought him over because my friends are  jerks and and I I just like started  really freaking out and he asked me if I  was on mushrooms and I was like no I am  dead sober this is just me did you tell  him how you felt about him no I just  kind of just kept smiling and just be  like dude dude Jesse Uncle Jesse  [Applause]